Film Courage: What is the most nervous you’ve
been as a performer?
Jonathan Mangum, Actor/Comedian/Announcer
for Let’s Make a Deal: The most nervous?
Ahhh…I went and screen tested for Saturday
Night Live and there were five of us. They
fly you to New York, get up on stage and I
knew they were going to tape me but I didn’t
realize they were going to tape me with the
actual cameras that they…the big cameras.
I mean it wasn’t like a little video camera
thing. The camera dude was there with the
camera. You are on the monologue stage and
at the table was Tina Fey and Lorne Michaels
and two or three other people and that was
SO nerve-racking because there are only 5
people watching you. Even if what you’re
doing is hilarious and they’re laughing,
it’s not going to sound like a wall of laughter.
And that year it was Fred Armisen, Will Forte,
my good friend Jeff Davis and another guy
I kind of knew. All five of us were going
up the elevator going “Hey man good luck
to you!” “Good luck to you!” And we
were all in the same boat together. So we
went in and did our audition which I thought
it did pretty well and we are walking out
and all of us are getting into the elevator
and were were “Oh, you guys want to go get
a drink? That was crazy, that was scary. You
guys want to go get a drink?” And right
as the doors are closing someone’s hand
goes “Fred, can you come with us?” And
we were like “Aaarrrghh! Couldn’t you
have waited for tomorrow to tell him he got
it so we could all bond and have a good time?
That was super scary but also I think I mentioned
earlier it’s not about who is best. It’s
about what they need at the time. Did they
need a six foot two white guy at the time?
It’s all about fits into the cast at that
moment so I feel better about that now but
afterwards I was like “Oh I must have been
terrible.” But I wasn’t.
Film Courage: Was that another lesson on not
getting your hopes up to much? When you get
an opportunity like that I’m sure you’re
super excited?
Jonathan: The problem with screen-testing
for anything in this town and getting your
hopes up is you have to sign the contract
before you test. So you have to sign a piece
of paper that shows you exactly how much money
you’re going to make every month and how
many years. You sign the deal before you test.
Everyone who tests for every sitcom and every
sitcom, every show on TV there are going to
be three or four people that go in for the
network test and before they do they all have
to…so you’re looking at the money like
“Oh my gosh, I could have all of this money?”
You have to sign it ten times and initial
on 15 pages and turn it in and then you audition.
So yeah…you shouldn’t get your hopes up.
You should just do your best but at the time
it’s like “Oh my gosh.” You’ve seen
all the numbers of that piece of paper. Just
in the back of your mind you’re like “Oh,
I could really use all that money.”
Film Courage: Well that is where your psychology
degree came in handy.
Jonathan: Right, I should have listened. If
I’d gotten a B I probably would have been
happier.
Film Courage: It would be very difficult to
see that and go in and audition.
Jonathan: It’s tough, yes. Network testing
is the scariest thing. And of all of the ones
I’ve tested for SNL was the most scariest.
Film Courage: Yes, I think Marc Maron spoke
about how he auditioned and waiting outside
and “Yeah, thanks kid.”
Jonathan: Marc was bitter about it for years
and then if you listened he had Lorne on his
podcast [WTF with Marc Maron] and they had
a nice…what’s the word? Reconciliation.
Film Courage: The nice thing is he’s upfront
about being bitter. I know some people criticize
him for that. I think it’s great because
he’s pretty much vocalizing what most people
think anyway. But I know he’s been criticized
for that. But it’s a great story.